la agencia para los refugiados de las
naciones unidas- ha asegurado que más de
4 millones de personas ya han abandonado
ucrania en las últimas semanas desde que
comenzó la invasión rusa el 24 de
febrero la mayoría de ellos son mujeres
con niños y personas mayores como lo
pudimos presenciar en nuestra salida
ayer de ucrania a través de hungría un
país que también es receptor de estos
refugiados al menos 400.000 personas han
llegado a este país en las últimas
semanas muchos de ellos llegan aquí en
tren desde budapest viene desde la
frontera con ucrania y son recibidos en
esta estación o los fueron recibidos
hasta hace pocos días porque el gobierno
del presidente viktor orbán ha
programado una nueva estructura la
mayoría de ellas llegan a una estación
en el perímetro de budapest son
recibidos en autobuses y son luego
traídos hacia el gran coliseo de la
ciudad donde hay una gran operación para
darles a primeros nivel los apoyos que
ellos necesitan muchas de las personas
que llegan a hungría siguen hacia otros
países de la región sin embargo este
informe de las naciones unidas- también
que el mayor receptor sigue siendo
polonia con casi dos millones y medio de
refugiados también lo es rumanía donde
ha aumentado el éxito en las últimas
semanas como consecuencia las personas
que vienen del sur y del centro del país